all right i'm trying this again
let's see if this is
i think it is working
um
okay guys
[Music]
hold on guys sorry
um
okay let's
i'm just trying to see if this is
working
let me see in the comments
okay cool i think it is can i add a
thumbnail for this live
because i was gonna finish the live that
i did the other day where i was reacting
to fresh and fit
i meant to do this a while ago but
i've been like traveling and stuff but
hold on guys do you think i can can i
like switch mid live can i add a
thumbnail to a live
okay i guess i won't
um okay let me go to fresh and fit i'm
gonna pull it up
i reacted to half of it the other day
so
let's see
um
sorry i was trying to let me know in the
comments if the audio was good because
i've been having like
issues with it lately so i've been
trying to like
re okay
we're gonna go
oh gosh okay
this is where i left off and then let me
know in the comments if the sound is
good
i'm gonna just
here let's see
my face is whiter than miracle whip god
damn guys okay i'm i swear i'm not like
as pale as i look
on camera the lighting in this room just
is not great
um okay but wait i'm gonna play this
the video and let me know if the audio
levels are okay no it wasn't it was
average average average guy 60k yeah
spoken mic um oh yeah okay 60k and um
was he attractive uh he is very
attractive okay but um
tall tall
actually he was my same height that was
the first time okay it was a first timer
i'm usually always with like six four
and up like but i was like you know what
i want to give this guy a chance he's
simple you know i've never really been
with a friend
it's not that he cheated oh he didn't
cheat
i just it's just being with me and you
don't have a kid so you don't know what
it's like to be a father you know what
i'm saying i've been through that so you
know for somebody to sit there and say
your child is draining me when all i
need you to do is just watch him to go
to sleep or you know to go to sleep so i
could come back and make my bread how
you could go in the morning to go make
your bread
to hear those words that my child drains
you i automatically just picked up all
my [ __ ] and left
because you're not the man for me yeah
because how are you going to sit here
and say that to me my child so i
remember watching this and thinking
um on one hand like
maybe that isn't the man for her but i
remember thinking maybe she let him go a
little too soon like that's a lot to ask
oh drains since they [ __ ] won
the first four the first two months
every three hours you don't understand
what i'm saying like
i had to sit there and be on call for my
baby so so you can't even put this [ __ ]
to sleep and you telling me that he's
draining you come on bro
was he like accept that
yeah your kid yeah he was for how long
for a good five months all right put
yourself in his shoes right remember you
just said you can't comprehend my new
pause
before i added my child into the
situation we were talking you understand
what i'm saying there was time before i
brought my child in you knew that i have
a child and i had my way to work around
it but you enjoyed my free time with you
now we move in
and there's a baby involved
he just he couldn't handle the pressure
and he folded like a napkin okay so i'm
gonna tell you this right because that
happened to me i i met a chick
we had time together a free time when
she wasn't with her child and we hung
out it was great times right however
moved in i married her and uh stupid
i had no idea
what it took to be a stepdad no
once i understood what i really took
i was like god damn i'm 22 years old
this [ __ ] ain't for me
now that being said right
i took it from hyaline from the hood
water permanent pines i'm saying tuck it
here changed their whole life right
now now that being said
i was like you know what damn
it's unfair to me to say you know what
i'm gonna love my girl
and then
not love her kid the same way cause it's
not my kid
so but that environment itself though
like think about this right the guy is
single
doesn't have any kids right exactly so
he can't possibly understand what you're
going through with your kid he might
want to but it's just like damn like
this is this is not even
my responsibility so i get what you're
saying i'm just so big i'm just so big
on
i could do this i could do this you tell
me you could do this and i put you to
the test and you fold it's just so i you
become disgusting to me like i'm so big
on the truth and holding your word and
especially you being a man because a man
is supposed to hold his word and you
know what i'm saying like if you say
this you're going to do this and if you
know a woman we're indecisive
i was also really tired
i would say from experience now going
through that whole process you might
want to get a guy with some kids just
because they no automatically like um
don't get me wrong i'm speaking to
somebody and he has two kids but he i've
known him since like i was in high
school we've been on and off talking and
it's just like
i see him more as a father figure but
not towards my kid because at the end of
the day right now i just it's just me
and legacy right now to be real i just i
can't i can't add another man right now
i can't i can't
okay all right well uh
as always i'm the guy that has to give
the uncomfortable truth but i'm gonna
say it anyway this is what men will
never admit
but
most men are not okay with raising a
child that isn't biologically theirs
we understand that and and the thing is
is that they might say no it's okay i'm
the dad that stepped up blah blah blah
a lot of guys that are stepfathers are
not stepfathers out of choice their
stepfather's out of necessity i'm gonna
say that again real nice and slow slow
it down i'll just do it
[Music]
most guys are stepfathers not because
they want to be but because of out of
necessity you guys got to understand
that the sexual urge for a man is
extremely powerful okay
so a lot of guys will say and do stupid
[ __ ] to get sexual access even if it
puts themselves in a compromising
position right that doesn't necessarily
benefit them to the highest degree we
told you guys earlier well most women
treat sex as a value loaded exchange hey
i'll give you a box if you
take me on a date uh marry me blah blah
a step dad is like super leverage
because he's coming in taking care of a
child that isn't his and not only that
he's investing emotionally in something
that isn't his own seed if you were to
break up with him not only does he lose
you but now he loses the children and
then on top of that that money that time
that effort that he put into raising
that child guess what he can't go to the
courts and be like hey
i want to see my kid i put him through
college and everything else can i please
see him well not college but i put him i
put him through a prep school right high
school i put him through prep school and
he's he's 16 now i want to see him in
his game judge is like uh no and then
the mom is there like
i don't disagree with this i think when
given the option most men um will choose
a girl with kids or without kids over a
girl with kids um
however like i think some guys will
still do it if the girls fit feminine
friendly enough um
i think ex-wives tend to get remarried
most of the time
you ain't never gonna see the kids so a
lot of guys know from like an innate
level that like it's not in your best
interest to invest in a child that isn't
your seed so a lot of guys aren't
prepared to do it a lot of guys become
step dads because they have to be now um
the other thing going back to a cheating
right
i want all the ladies in here because a
lot of you guys mentioned that you would
not share your guy right
mender's only faithful is there options
that's uncomfortable truth
you take the best guy
nice guy
came from a good household whatever give
that guy a lamborghini a mansion and a
blue check mark on instagram he's
smashing everybody a lot of guys are
faithful again by necessity okay or
maybe a religious constraint whatever it
is there's a necessity though like what
what what will make a man faithful by
necessity
sexual access
if i don't commit
i will not get sex i don't have the
value
to play the game and be polygamous and
or have multiple women okay
contrary to popular belief ladies these
guys are not all here [ __ ]
a small percentage of men are [ __ ]
all the girls to be exact somewhere
between 10 to 20 percent of guys are
smashing like 90 of the women what does
that mean
that means i know you're like what the
[ __ ] no i was about to say my sperm
donor
you know what i'm saying so exactly so
so since most guys can't get sexual
access it's a scarce commodity to a
majority of men
right so
okay so so if a guy wants to get wants
to get laid
he's either got to a increase his value
and be attractive to a large demographic
of women get his money right learn game
get in the gym et cetera become a catch
which is so many times where i wanted to
like ask him a question but he'll this
is what he does he says like
ten sentences in a row and since there's
like it's his show right and there's so
many of you you don't want to like
interject every single time but it's
like
it'll be like statement statement
statement statement statement like
so
you kind of have to break down like each
and every one
because men must become
or b
stay the level he's at find a girl that
might not be the hottest might have a
kid or two might uh cheat on him might
might have two husbands right two
boyfriends which we've seen that before
on the show woman that had two guys
and tolerate that why because his body's
not high enough to play the game so
settled so settle exactly but men are
far more willing to settle than women
are that's the difference
because we don't have the privilege of
choice like women do
right so um
so that's what it is so i say this
the higher the status the man that you
deal with the more attractive the more
money he makes that whatever it is the
higher the likelihood you're gonna have
to share them are there guys out there
that won't challenge you you're
completely fine with me okay in a sense
because if they're if we have a business
together and you're a man of high
standards you know what i'm saying i'm
i'm more for making my [ __ ] go you know
as long as you have my respect and at
least as long as you tell me i was so
nervous the whole time like the first
especially the first time i was on the
show i've never been on like a live
podcast before
so there were so many times where i
really wanted to just be like
interject but i'm kind of polite i have
a hard time interjecting about it you
know like i just i like to know yeah you
just wanna you just wanna i really it's
like oh well here's the thing though
[ __ ] another [ __ ] today no no imagine
i [ __ ] another [ __ ] today look i'm
gonna just let you know what's up and
whatever i'ma let you know what's up and
it is what it is i'm gonna just look at
him all right what do you want to eat
okay hold on one sec hold on i've been
there i've been there you can't tell me
different i am not captain take it off
pick it off here you said it five years
take it all off you said you're better
but i'm talking from an experience right
now and and i took notes you said hey
i mean i could share him but i'm jealous
as hell i am it's easy for you to say
this 2012 like 2020 hindsight right now
with us but let's say you're with this
man he's invested money in you he's your
boyfriend he's your serious counterpart
he comes in and says he gave him the
[ __ ] his dick ain't gonna work for five
days because i know a spell's gonna come
out
you can say that you can say that right
now but a woman's emotions are always
erratic
it is what it is y'all y'all are not the
same data just be real with you i'll
just be breaking phones okay well
so the point is is that he can't be
honest about it most women can't handle
the truth we tell you guys why did these
podcasts pop in regardless of the haters
we got 8 700 live viewers so i have a
question if their podcast
gets less viewers would it be because
they don't tell the truth
it's that
same logic
like that was always my
like caveat being on the show is they
just think
they have the ultimate truth like i know
everything it's just like an arrogant no
we've we've basically from interviewing
hundreds of women they say just be
honest with me most girls can't handle
the truth
that's why guys lie
yeah
make sure our feelings are not hurt
because they don't want to hurt us oh
yeah
you have something
get a nokia
get a nokia yeah those phones are
unbreakable
do you think guys over 250 000 have
options yes
yeah well should we say that for her
question though
yeah because that's a good that's that's
a good uh that's a good question no it's
like i'm leading into something oh
you're leaving
just yesterday oh yeah yeah yeah for
absolutely okay more money in man makes
the more doors right so you'd say like
obviously then the likelihood of them
cheating goes up because over 250 000
it's about 50
but that means like 50 don't
you know what i mean so you're saying
like all men will cheat when they have
the chance but like based on the stats
like i'm pretty sure i've heard that on
either your show or the kevin samuels
show it increases the likelihood of
marriage sting
what it does is when a man earns a
certain amount of money what it does is
it decreases the chances of divorce it
does not decrease the chances of
infidelity no that's not what i'm saying
okay what do you think what i'm saying
is you're saying that every like that
men when given the option they will
cheat
and what i'm saying
yeah like it's more likely and i agree
with you there but what i'm saying is
that like still fifty percent don't
because you see he switches there like
i said do all men when given the option
will they cheat he says yes and then
after he switches it surveyed like over
250 000 goes from 25 percent to 50
so that means half the cheat half don't
you know what i mean are you gonna
believe a study where they're asking the
guy are you cheating or not yeah i mean
that's the one that they cite right i'm
sure you got to remember that that like
women lie about their body counts guys
are going to lie about infidelity yep
okay
like men have a serious stake in lying
about infidelity because here's the
thing once a man is married especially
if he's married he has way more to lose
okay so the way you view it like your
world view is like that they all cheat
they just don't admit it over 250 000
yeah like like th
like the thing is this
he they're not going to admit oh yeah i
banged the mistress here or hey i dealt
with this girl my my the more
the more money and status of man makes
the more options open and the thing is
is that for men we don't get the same
sexual access that you guys do
so for you guys it's easy to turn down
dick because it comes at you every day
but as a man it's very difficult to get
to the point where women actually lust
for you it's rare you have money see he
goes on this is why i would get so
frustrated because i'd ask him like one
question like yes or no and then he
would say yes go on a tangent and i'm
like trying to talk about one thing
yeah if you have money if you have
satisfied these [ __ ] be ugly yeah like
like you know what i'm saying that like
for a man to get sexual access is
extremely difficult so i wouldn't go off
of a self-performance survey like
because
the way you're talking is like no matter
what the survey says like i'm going to
believe what i believe regardless of the
facts which is what you tend to go
against
that was so funny because the way he
talks is like i could have any data in
front of me but this is how i think the
world is
and it's totally fine to say
you know
from what i've seen in the world this is
what i believe regardless of whatever
study that i see i mean people have
opinions all the time that aren't rooted
in fact fine but stand on that
like right okay this study that you're
talking about if this is a study that
i'm thinking about they surveyed married
men yeah and they found that married men
uh what's it called marriages stay
longer but that does not that that
you're talking about divorce rates go
down no i'm not i'm talking about
cheating statistics so it's about like
28
and also when i looked it up after the
show because the one the one thing they
don't tell you about coming on the show
you don't know the topic so how prepared
are you gonna be for a show
where they say it's like men and women
dating dynamics or something super broad
so i got lucky where i actually like
have studied a decent amount on like
cheating and stuff but
you go in blind so
i'm it was
i said 50 on the show but i'm pretty
sure it's like 35 to 42 percent i
actually do admit to it
around 25
under 250 000 and bumps up to 50 over
250 000.
seriously it bumps up the cheating
increases as they make more money yes
which i agree with you there but like
your your whole point is you basically
think that every it seems like and you
can tell me if i'm wrong you think that
everybody cheats when they're given the
option so if
men over 250 000 have the option to
cheat but the surveys which is like what
you saying half of them yeah so i'm
saying like which says it only it says
only half of them cheap yeah
since it's a separate point even let's
say let's up it to 75 that means one and
four don't and that's what i'm saying
like some guys like have that discipline
and have that like those values you know
no i'm serious
and this is why they're laughing because
like if they think never in a million
years could i ever be faithful that's
that's fine oh hold on speak of the
devil my dad's calling me
hi dad
i'm in my loft
oh really sorry i'm doing a reaction
video
right now
oh uh
what
wait say that again
oh is it there
oh yay
okay i'll come down
wait
did you open it is it it
wait really
okay hold on i'm gonna come down
i'll i'll end my live
hold on
hold on hold on okay
what
wait say it again
yeah that'd be great actually if you
don't mind yay right
he said he's gonna bring it up to me
sorry guys
um
um okay okay
that's what i said okay this is what
we're talking about in the chat everyone
come on sure maybe half maybe 75 but
everyone that's too general like
there are guys that don't think it's
worth it they don't think it's worth
hurting their wife they don't think it's
worth losing possibly possibly losing
their family
because like you know and someone said
oh any guy will do it if he's tempted
long enough fair enough right but that's
why you don't put yourself in situations
where you're tempted oh my gosh my dad's
calling again
um
wait you called me again
oh okay
okay are you in my room
okay i'll see you soon
dad why are you screaming
thank you
yeah
i get to go stand beside you
wait i'm on a stream just so you know
that's fine i just i don't want you
saying any of my embarrassing secrets
yay
oh my gosh that picture they took me is
so ugly
yeah i know oh my gosh this is so
exciting
yay guys yay i get to go to england
i've been waiting on my visa
okay sorry i'm gonna go back a little
bit sorry for the interruptions guys
that is the man the myth of the legend
my father he brought me my visa
and i just got it approved so i get to
go to england yay
so the way you're talking is like no
matter what the survey says like i'm
gonna believe what i believe regardless
of the facts which is what you tend to
go against that was my most fire line
i'm sorry i don't care what anyone says
that was my most fire line you're gonna
believe what you believe regardless of
the facts which is what you tend to go
against that was fire because that's
what they in guys this is what i want to
clarify i am not against believing
things because it's what you've seen in
the world
i
stats can be manipulated
in so many ways there's nothing wrong
with that but stand on it
stand on that you know
okay this study that you're talking
about if this is a study that i'm
thinking about they surveyed married men
yeah and they found that married men uh
what's it called marriages stay longer
but that does not that that you're
talking about divorce rates go down stop
telling me what i'm saying i'm not
talking about divorce rates i'm not i'm
talking about cheating statistics so
it's about like 28
like around 25
under 250 000 and bumps up to 50 over
250 000. so you're saying it bumps up
the cheating increases as they make more
money yes which i agree with you there
but like your your whole point is you
basically think that ever it seems like
and you can tell me if i'm wrong you
think that everybody cheats when they're
given the option so if
men over 250 000 have the option to
cheat
but the surveys which is like what you
saying half of them yeah so i'm saying
like which says only it says only half
of them cheat yeah i'll be since this is
a separate point even let's say let's up
it to 75 that means one and four don't
and that's what i'm saying like some
guys like have that discipline and have
that like those values
no i'm serious
i hated that they're laughing i thought
that was so disrespectful i was like
stop laughing at me well
because like you know most people drink
like my dad's never drank in his life
most people have social media my dad's
never had social media in his life your
father is also significantly older than
guys now
you got you ladies you got to understand
what's happened but see now he's moving
the goal post he's like oh it's because
your dad's old like
like
if anything i think it was easier to
cheat back then because you've less of a
digital trail now there's like cameras
everywhere
there's messages people can screenshot
like there's too much of a trail is that
the world has globalized okay not just
globalized from an economy standpoint in
gdp blah blah no no it's globalized from
a sexual market standpoint too right
what's happened is the women that are
attractive have more options and the men
that are attractive and have money and
status have more options as well so
we know that most women deal one want a
very
a small selective man right most guys
are invisible to that most guys are
invisible to them so
with that the guys that have the ability
to are [ __ ] all the girls i
understand where you're coming from like
hey your dad is come from a different uh
cloth but times have changed
significantly and also i would be
interested to see that study the age of
the men surveyed
because we need if we're going to look
at a study we need to look at everything
and remember it's self-reported right 50
are admitting they've cheated over over
250 000 remember these are married men
right if a man admits that he's cheating
guess what happens there are serious
consequences because we live in a world
now where there's no fault of force so
women can literally say where's the
consequence in an anonymous survey at
any point hey hey matt you could walk
into the house hey babe what's going on
she's sucking another dude's dick looks
at you dead in the eye says oh yeah um
we're divorcing and it goes back to what
she's doing men have no real protection
once he marries a woman yeah you got
pronucial agreements and everything else
like that but like a lawyer yeah with a
good lawyer you know what i'm saying
once you make a certain amount of money
she's been with you through a for a
certain amount of time there's no way
you're getting you're getting cleaned so
i would be interested to see the
percentage the age of the men surveyed
and then also on top of that is
self-reported of married men okay
they're not gonna be honest so if like
because i don't know that off the top of
my head obviously but if it was like
over a wide range of ages would that
change your world view or would you just
not like care because like the way you
see it they're lying they obviously do
it
and he he doesn't watch he doesn't
answer my question i'm saying do the
stats
differ your opinion or do you believe
what you believe regardless of the facts
that is what we're talking about
it's okay i don't i don't have a problem
with people believing what they believe
regardless of the facts women do it all
the time
just stand on it thank you so much for
the donation guys i'm struggling
my parents
look it
they're great but i gotta i gotta fund
england
um so you guys are seriously like
funding that
and every donation helps so much so i
really really appreciate it so like so
you're saying if it were younger men
yeah like if if that survey included
young men old men i don't know if it was
young men i would i would be willing to
bet the cheating would go up
okay the cheating would go you'd be
willing to bet billy no answer like
that's that's what i kept asking him the
same question over and over again does
your opinion change or do you just
believe what you believe
because remember it used to be when your
dad was young yeah to get sexual access
you had to get married
right i said this i showed this video to
my mom funny thing and my mom was
like
she was like that was not the case at
all like
when they got pregnant like three months
after she met him like women weren't as
promiscuous as they are now he lived
with my mom like before they were
married but the point is is that your
mom was dating him with a purpose
correct for marriage more than likely
not not really she was 17.
um
i don't know maybe they dated for like
five years like she met him when she was
17. okay so like i do i think she was
trying to get married when she was 17 no
but like after five years yeah yeah so
so so the point is is that women aren't
as promiscuous uh sorry what
women see like i said something that
wasn't in line with what he said
like
what was my mom less promiscuous miss i
don't know at 17 she got knocked up
by a guy
that like
she just
like maybe known a month i don't know
two whatever it was
um i mean our families were friends
their families were friends so i think
it was a little different but like
is that that's not exactly like chase
you know my mom got lucky she married
that guy right but
is there a difference of promiscuity
more promiscuous now than ever before
it's it's it's all over culture it is
what it is it's cool you know what i'm
saying yeah so
i would i would argue that if you were
to survey younger people
it would be even more yeah guys
especially guys with money
so yeah because the thing is is that
there's so many guys that are invisible
to women the guys that are smashing the
girls are smashing all the girls and
that's that's actually the other stat um
i think it's a little dishonest in the
man of spirit i've heard that a lot like
the 2080 rule like 10 20 like it depends
who you listen to but 10 to 20 percent
but 50 of men are in relationships
so like
like that's not 10 to 20 if you're not
counting we always talk about single
guys right i'm talking about single guys
because you got to remember the 80 20
rule comes from single men right that
are that go on tinder okay cupid et
cetera and the women find most of them
is unattractive and the other question i
had um was what do you define as
sexually active like
in what time frame because there was a
study i just like looked it up before i
came here that said like 30 percent if
you look in the past year 30 of men
haven't had sex okay right so it's like
what do you define as sexually active
and that's so important
that's so important because the
definition he gives
makes it
incredibly dishonest to me like that's
gonna show you what you're saying but it
like so it would depend what you define
as sexually active
well here's the thing
remember you're saying hasn't had sex
yeah okay so um but that would mean like
oh my god i can't do that it's 70
percent like have in the last year yeah
well it's very common for guys to go
through because here's the thing a guy
might only have had sex once in a year
yeah and and and that will still
consider him as yeah they'll still
consider him for the purpose of that
study sexually actively right but like
guys that are consistently having sex
with new girls and or not in a
relationship far few between very rare
so i'm
asking like what is your definition of
sexually active like within what time
frame do you have any idea i would say
like a guy that can consistently pull
and or have sex with a multitude of
different women
okay so if you're having sex with one
woman woman you're not sexually active
like
like this is what i mean it's like they
they take the stat to make it as
fearmongering and like terrible as you
can portray it as possible so if you've
you have sex with one girl
you're not you're not sexually active
within a certain time span because the
thing is about um
because because here's the thing we're
talking about single guys that are on
tinder and okay cupid that are looking
for a potential other
uh woman and the women find these guys
as extremely unattractive right and then
you take that and you compile it also
with all the data coming out from
washington post whatever it is that
young men between 18 and 29 are
reporting the lowest levels of sexual
activity right then on top of that let's
add in the fact that there's been an
explosion of youtube channels teaching
guys how to get girls meanwhile there
has not been any channels teaching girls
had to get laid so look at this video
but there's a million channels
teaching girls how to get relationships
steve harvey
matthew hussey like the list goes on and
on and on yeah of course of course of
course but i'm just trying i'm just
trying to show that the the extreme
contrast between the two you know what
i'm saying so there's a problem and it's
worldwide i mean you guys see that we
got guys here from australia commenting
canada whatever if you look at a first
world country where women have are the
most liberated sexually that tends to
have a lot of the time the most
frustrated guy sexually because when you
leave a woman to her own devices what
does she do she picks the best of the
best most attractive guys bad boys
athletes celebrities rappers whatever it
may be so
um i think you're saying 50 of guys are
in relationships but that does not
necessarily mean they're smashing as a
matter of fact i would argue a lot of
times especially sexist marriages are a
thing when guys are relationships with
girls what happens you didn't take out
the trash
we're nuts right but how how prevalent
is that i don't
i think it's so wrong for a woman to
deprive someone
sexually like in a marriage especially
like in a relationship too but like i
think it's more common in a marriage
like i think that's wrong i think you
shouldn't do that um
let's see what's he gonna say um
that's relationships not
how sorry i got distracted
um
but like it's just this like negative
world view so
okay like yeah you know
the 2080 rule right 20 of men have
access to 80 of women unfortunate like
let's even say that's those numbers are
accurate
on top of that like i'm like oh well 50
of men are in relationships
well those guys aren't getting any like
okay what what data do you have magic
you know what i'm saying so um so it is
a serious problem for a lot of guys but
i see we're going with that though go
ahead you get some mess
wait so
then would you just say that
like the majority
of
like so you really think it's like only
ten to twenty percent of guys that are
smashing i've heard arguments that are
it's it's even less oh my gosh actually
i need to say something i blanked out
right before that i 100 blanked out
like it was getting late like you don't
understand it's like one two in the
morning
so you're starting to get tired like
tired as hell but you have this
adrenaline rush from like being on the
show
oh my gosh i remember i left but it was
like 4am about dating apps is that like
where they get the because the one thing
i will say is i don't really trust like
data from dating apps because one some
men like suck at taking pictures too i
think vocal tonality is something that
like women find really attractive and
this is what i said to rebecca
which
when i was on the live with her i was
like i'm not tripping vocal tonality
does so much like a guys that have deep
voices like that can
change them completely and she was even
saying that's what attracted her to her
husband you know like everyone knows
you've met a guy that's not cute but he
can make you laugh or he's funny or he
knows how to talk but i'm going to
respectfully disagree and i'll tell you
why dating apps is where people can be
extremely honest the data's honest so so
so the thing about dating apps is if you
and hell on this podcast why do you guys
think we have three hat four or five
hats next to us women always give the
politically correct answer they're not
gonna tell you what really turns them on
what around them or what turns them off
because a lot of the things that turn a
woman on are politically incorrect the
beauty with dating at data is that
you're going to get the uncomfortable
ugly truths for example this is the best
ever female argument i've seen on the
show
like what is it mic drop
example asian and indian men are the
least desired race
you ain't gonna find that out just by
going around asking you know what i'm
saying you need to get that i don't know
i think i could get that information
just by asking to be honest a data where
there's a little bit of anonymity and
you have a little bit of protection so
that is why dating app data is so good
is because you see what people really
like i just don't i don't think so
because like to me i think girls like
looks is not at the top of like what
they look for minus height i'll give
i'll give you like girls like height but
on dating apps you can make preferences
which you want to show up for you and
you can like limit the other people like
you said which percentage are more
attractive
who hasn't set a little preference on
there don't even bother like i'm not i
don't you don't need to swipe on
somebody such a preference right you
know so i mean so you might not even get
on her feed is what i'm trying to say
like i can limit you because i'm like
you know what i already know what i'm
into so i'm just
i'm not even going to bother so you know
that's why it's there it's for that so
so i get what we were saying like you're
saying
i get understand your argument you're
saying well dating apps aren't accurate
representation like that well i mean
you're basically saying that like
because i hated
like oh my gosh
i wasn't mad at all but i was just like
i did not talk like that
get out of here i don't think so the
argument is this simply put the argument
is this i don't think the dating apps
are an accurate representation of what's
going on in the real modern dating world
right yes i would argue that it is very
similar if anything probably a little
bit more uh
a little bit more
less on the men's side actually i have a
question then
i think the answer to that question i'm
just thinking out loud like are dating
apps an accurate representation of
what's going on in the dating
marketplace right now i guess the
question would be to look at people in
relationships and marriages and ask
where they met
would you guys agree or disagree i'm
just thinking out loud of how you could
get that answer even yes like you you're
saying well can you go out there and uh
talk to a woman that might not
necessarily have found you the most
attractive but winner over yeah sure
yeah let's be honest a lot of guys don't
have game yeah okay a lot of guys don't
understand social calibration a lot of
guys don't know how to take a woman
that's low interest and turn it into a
high interest hell on this podcast we
even tell guys don't don't don't go with
interest girls don't even do it don't
even do it so
see how many filters have to be met for
him to even to build attraction from the
first place so i would argue it's even
more pronounced than what's on the
dating apps
you know what i'm saying what makes you
stand out compared to anyone else who
said exactly well and the other thing i
was thinking about is like
if you go to photofeeler.com guys you
can have them rate your pictures
and like you can have women write your
pictures or men rate your pictures and i
guarantee based on a picture you can go
up or down like three or four points and
that's what i mean like some guys really
don't know how to take pictures well
you've said to me
just you know like a week ago you know
so i could i'd be like no i'm not and
here's the thing it sucks like that it's
that it's like that now but that that's
what happened like
um your mother and father's time was a
golden era and you that's actually when
the united states was at its peak
uh nuclear family cocaine uh hey yeah
miami
that's a little bit before this but but
like you know family really meant a
family was a thing marriages lasted
longer the divorce rate wasn't as high
but that's not even true
my parents generation is the generation
that brought down the
divorce rate
like
like that that's the generation that got
divorced when they met in the 90s have
such a high initiation of divorce from
women to men so two-parent households
literally lead to um are a great
predicate on having children that are
not going to be degenerates in society
but it's disintegrated so what's
happened now is we have an open sexual
marketplace right where it's deregulated
as long as both parties are of consent
and um so both parties consent and both
parties are age of consent you can bang
anything really so
if you leave
and who who are the sexual selectors
well last time i checked women pick who
has sex otherwise you're gonna go to
jail for a long time so um so what that
said if you leave women to their own
devices they pick the best of the best
is what it is so
you know can a guy go in and build
interest and approach and maybe it won't
be like the dating apps yeah but that's
far from between man a lot of guys uh
aren't gonna be able to take a girl
that's low interest and raise her uh her
interest level unless he appeal i don't
i am i've i've seen guys do it like i've
seen guys but i hear what you're saying
i do like think there's some truth in
what you're saying i just think there's
like more to it than just like dating
app data
i mean if anything the dating app data
makes it a little bit uh i'm sure
there's anything i'm sure there is but
the thing is like what other data is
there to look at at this point that's a
fair point that's a 100 a fair point
like what other data do you look at
that's true because that's open right
now
the most honest data is bing app data
yeah and this this to be real like even
from your experiences that's what you're
seeing for yourself and there's like
numerous articles that guys are
reporting the lowest levels of having
sex man [ __ ] we talk to them every day
yeah like like i mean like it's it's and
here's the thing like i don't expect you
to understand i don't expect any of you
ladies to understand the male struggle
whatsoever not nor should you we're not
on here to cry but it's tough for men to
get sex it is what it is you know
survival of the fittest right but what i
am saying is that it's a lot tougher
than women think and it's uh you know
women think well you should be able to
get girls
it doesn't it doesn't work that way man
because you could be a woman's type you
can be attractive you can say all the
things you need to say and she still
won't [ __ ] you yup that's the
uncomfortable truth
that's the truth well i think it's
because girls when when they um do hook
up with someone like it's more for a
relationship
you know that's like like they might not
say it but i think a lot of girls that's
their english not all the time
for you guys
like
don't agree with that i just want some
dick
it's not even about just having
something it's like all right you
talking to me i want to see what you
about and then i chill with you i see
what you're about and like your vibe is
just not my vibe so yeah i just think
okay sorry
i just think girls when they hook up
with someone it's more closer to someone
that they'd want a relationship where
guys will hook up with someone
and it's more closer
to like pretty much anything
that's what they talk about in this so
for the dinner yeah thank you for the
nice stuff bye-bye are you talking about
a date or you're saying like you're
hooking up with this hooking up date
whatever it is i get [ __ ] out of people
so i you got to give me something before
we could [ __ ] my name i don't want to
[ __ ] you it's that's your bad
that's just me though the point is is
that men have to check off a lot of
boxes they can check off all the boxes
and still not get the sexual access
that's true because the unfortunate
reality is let's say okay let's say i uh
go up to a girl right and um she's i'm
her type i'm everything that she wants
tall dark handsome whatever maybe i
might trigger you on youtube i don't
know but i go up to her hey what's up if
she's having a bad day she's gonna say
uh nope i'm good and walk away it is
what it is women are are slaves to their
emotions boars and they say every day a
guy before you gave her an imprint and
she loves that guy so much you know what
no i'm cool i'm i'm single but i want to
just say she might have got a dm from a
guy boom there you go she don't even
have to meet him it could be a guy
that's attractive that hit her up so
i get it like i get her saying like well
are the studies actually represented
representative
do you notice how he was about to mock
me again
and then he stopped
that's why i was laughing
dating landscape i would argue yes and
if anything it's even worse than the
data says because we have the data from
coaching thousands of men guys having uh
the guys being in the chat the explosion
of this type of content getting out
there there's a serious problem
sorry that was a really weird yawn for
men with getting sexual access so i
would argue it's probably even worse
than 2080 but just to be conservative i
would say
20 80 and then again we're saying well
what about relationships well those guys
are a lot of sexless relationships girls
are finessing dudes do you do you know
that for sure that they're in sexless
relations i'm just curious because i've
never looked at data from that i'm just
curious there's a lot of sexless
relationships well i know they're
definitely
but that's what i'm saying is there data
to back this up or is this just a lot of
people probably people also date for
comfortability not necessarily sexual or
yeah there's two main predicators
most relationships don't work is because
money and cheating okay that's the fact
so it's like over time you see people um
they get together for convenience
whatever but either money not working
out or them cheating breaks them apart
and i'll take it a step further remember
i always said on this podcast most guys
get into relationships out of necessity
if you get into a relationship about a
necessity guess who has leverage the
woman girl the one providing him and
when the woman nah i mean possibly
possibly but regardless the woman has a
leverage because i'm getting into a
relationship now because i need sex
since i need sex she now has a leverage
guess what happens hey you didn't take
the trash out hey you didn't do this now
you start to do what roller always says
negotiate desire you can't negotiate
desire but a lot of guys find themselves
in that predicament where they're
negotiating desire in relationships with
a girlfriend let alone
a wife
that's why we tell guys don't move in
with your girl yeah if you move in it's
a wrap it's dangerous
so
we brought up some no thank you so much
for bringing up those claims i'm going
to give you a dynamic
[Music]
because we need to have these
discussions you know these educated
discussions but that's what i would say
of course yeah
sorry do you have something else oh hold
on yes all right we can come back to you
let the other girls have some other
stuff wait
um
so i say the first time i was on the
show i actually had like a lot of fun
like it was a positive experience
okay i need to figure out some stuff for
england though
i may or may not finish this
a different day their shows are so long
so long
um but guys
feel free to subscribe please
send a donation if you can i'm trying to
trying to get to england
as you guys know
um don't forget to subscribe to the
channel did i say that leave a comment
let me know if you agree or you disagree
all comments are a good comment